[Música]
y justamente hoy en directo Ah nos
desplazamos a Bolivia se cumplen 26 días
de paro en Santa Cruz pasaron las 72
horas que los líderes de la huelga
dieron para que el gobierno liberara los
manifestantes detenidos entre otras
propuestas y eps a que hubo avances
ahora anuncian que continuarán con los
bloqueos y las protestas conectamos con
Mary vaca corresponsal de France 24 en
La Paz Mary qué balance se puede hacer
de estos 26 días de paro
Hola Qué tal Buenas noches se puede
decir que es hasta ahora el paro más
largo del que se tenga memoria en
Bolivia y si bien ha sido un paro que ha
sido acatado y seguido por la mayor
parte de la población del departamento
de Santa Cruz también hay que decir que
ha sido una movilización violenta de
ambos lados que significa eso que los
movimientos sociales que apoyan al
presidente Luis Arce también han tenido
su parte en estos actos de violencia
pues ellos han protagonizado para
empezar un cerco en torno a la ciudad de
Santa Cruz para impedir el ingreso o
salida de alimentos también han hecho un
bloqueo en torno a la refinería de Palma
sola para evitar que salga combustible
hacia la ciudad y finalmente han
protagonizado marchas de protesta y una
de estas marchas ha derivado en
enfrentamientos durísimos con los grupos
cívicos estos grupos cívicos por su
parte han desplazado a sus bloqueadores
hacia las sedes sindicales de estos
sectores sociales y han provocado la
quema de una de esas sedes y daños
serios en otros puntos y
establecimientos de El del presidente
Luis Arce o de grupos que apoyan al
presidente el Luis Arce por otro lado
hay que decir que durante estos 26 días
de paro ya se han producido tres
fallecimientos en diversas
circunstancias en lo que va de la medida
de presión también hay varios heridos
más de una veintena de detenidos y las
pérdidas económicas son cuantiosas según
los cálculos del gobierno hasta la fecha
el país habría perdido cerca de mil
millones de dólares por estas protestas
por su parte el gobierno de Luis arce y
particularmente el presidente acusado a
los líderes de la protesta y al
gobernador de Santa Cruz de esta
desestabilizando a su gobierno de estar
queriendo hacer un golpe de estado ellos
han rechazado la denuncia asegurando que
lo único que buscan es que el censo de
población y vivienda se realicen 2023 y
no el 2024 adentro como pretende el
gobierno de Luis Arce Mary justamente
usted estaba mencionando algo al
respecto ya se anunció que la huelga
continúa entonces que exigen los
manifestantes en estos momentos
para entender lo que exigen debo
contarles que el último fin de semana El
domingo se ha realizado en Santa Cruz un
Cabildo masivo de la ciudadanía con gran
participación se dice también que ha
sido el Cabildo más grande de los
últimos tiempos en esa región en el que
han decidido exigir que un decreto de
Luis Arce que dispone que el censo se
realice en marzo de 2024 se eleve al
Rango de ley por otro lado han exigido
que se liberen a todos los detenidos
Pues bien hoy el presidente del comité
cívico Pro Santa Cruz Rómulo calvo ha
señalado que el paro Va a continuar
mientras no se liberen a todos los
detenidos faltan 4 por liberar y por
otro lado esperan que esta ley del censo
se apruebe lo antes posible en el
parlamento sin embargo durante esta
jornada tanto la cámara de senadores
como la de diputados han rechazado el
ingreso de los proyectos de ley del
censo porque consideran que no sean
cumplidos los trámites de rutina que se
debería cumplir antes de meter los
proyectos de ley a su votación por lo
tanto el paro según Rómulo calvo Va a
continuar hasta que esta ley sea
aprobada sin embargo hay que decir que
los cívicos están insistiendo con que en
esta ley se ponga que el censo debe
realizarse el año 2023 y no el 2024 como
ha dispuesto el presidente Luis Arce en
un decreto